okay
hello yes sir hey how you doing hey
sorry to bother you I'm Fernando I'm a
big energy we're a few door now we're in
1845. okay so we do solar around here
we're just coming around talking
sorry dude neighbors I apologize
and the guy's black no yeah
oh
[ __ ] oh my God look at it watch this
watch this look should I go back and wow
should I go back and ask him if you want
solar panels he knows he's gonna need a
fire
everything man this is just like Ray
Rice you know what I'm saying you know
Donald exactly all that stuff you know
what I mean it's just you know that's
like like
that's one of those like
he that guy regularly talks like that do
you think okay so this is that was gonna
be my question yeah but that was gonna
be my question he just regularly talks
like that he's probably like when he's
in when he's with his friends or like
you know when he's like yeah man I'm on
this neighborhood talking to all these
you know that's just how he talks you
know what I mean like here's the thing
too I think I guess because people were
like people are prejudiced I think
people like when people use the word
race races right right racism implies to
me when you have power over someone and
you uh you you can change the you can
take money out of their pocket you can
stop them from doing things I don't
think like if there's like like say it's
like autism I think people's racism is
on the Spectrum too sure you know what
I'm saying you know so I I don't I'm not
quick to be like well this dude right
right right right I don't know if this
guy's necessarily like right hateful so
much as he's just like one of these
white guys right right Johnny [ __ ] up
you know what I mean yeah
he had the moment too he was like oh no
but also when he saw the bad guy in his
head he was saying the n-word and he's
like we're selling maybe solar panels
maybe it was like neighbor Neighbors
that's you know what I mean that's it's
not even really that close it's not that
close and it was a hard eel yeah it
wasn't like
when the Black dancer in his head his
initial reaction was oh that's a ninja
and then he said it out loud yeah maybe
I don't know I don't know I have no idea
that that was that is a that is crazy to
me that that happened what whatever kind
of mistake it is whether it's the oops
my racism is showing or I don't even
know I had a brain aneurysm or no matter
what it is it's such a [ __ ] up and so it
needs to be like listen I have CT I
played football in high school for two
years but the thing is is like this is
like you know the fact that you have
footage of it is what makes oh yeah oh
yeah because I'm saying how many moments
do normal people have like that not
talking about race no no no but just
sleeping oh like if you came in there
that's crazy but this yeah I couldn't
see it like that oh it's bad first of
all I wouldn't want to have my brain
fart moments recorded on a ring cam no
of course not you know what I mean but
it's like this guy's like you just want
to you just take it own it and move on I
heard you got a promotion but it just
sucks that that's a mistake and
Ming yeah